quando avevo 100 iscritti ho detto a me
compra una webcam bella più più o meno
che era questa qui in realtà fa un po
cagare però vabbè come o quattro ho
visto guardato il canale ieri visto che
c'erano quattro milioni e 100 mila
iscritti e ho cambiato la webcam nel
sochaux questa qui è molto più fluida di
quella di prima adesso posso fare così è
riuscita ad apprezzare ogni singola
immagine di questo video ho giocato con
i miei amici a due tre giochi e gli ho
mixati insieme in un solo video così da
testare un pochettino la webcam nuova
quindi tre gameplay un po a caso buona
visione
mi spiego io io sto testando la webcam
quella nuova perché i 60fps quindi ogni
tanto faccio movimenti per vedere se
funziona il fluire la fluidità
secondo questo se magari riusciamo anche
a vincere la partita
la mancata sono regole non toccava via
non ti voglio vedere tanto che pensa
comunque la palla scarsa tirati dietro è
tutto nelle tue mani
ho anche fatto cadere la nocciolina
madonna che reali sembra abbiamo uno
spasmo su joystiq vai vai vai è scemo
buttare in mezzo a te la lascio a te
pietro tutto danno di immagine
bravo sei entrato su infarto
l'ho tolto questa terra guardate su
tutti gli uomini sei da solo da solo da
solo devi andare in porta in porta in
porta in porta pietro importa
calcolatissimo tu volevi fare così la
banda di scimmie una banda di scimmie
per fa quando non riesci a segnare e
allora appartenerle avversario auto pole
si levano tutti porca miseria porca
porca miseria
un gol gol pietro pietro no a i can't
believe it porta vuota
allora ognuno i suoi limiti
felice ho trovato un cespuglio aiutami
vedere vogliamo cespuglio ti vogliamo
mi sto attaccando il cespuglio addosso
sono un cespuglio la vita è bella
ragazzi adesso oggi vi insegno come si
gioca questo gioco ciao amici sono
l'uomo ciao d'artagnan sono l'uomo
cespuglio cosa ne pensi di questo gioco
grazie ma come funziona qua come amico
mi esce un po la testa se guardi bene
hai mai visto un cespuglio a 60 fps
funziona se sparo mismi scompare no se
ti sparano scompare indebolita secondo
te è un cespuglio sul letto è normale mi
si chiama rilevano la normalità e porca
put e spavento sono il cespuglio mannaro
vieni qua pubblica c1
io faccio cespuglio e tre molto che
floro flore il king o cespuglio e vi
vengo a salvarsi momenti molto piacere
amici mi dispiace grazie dove vinceremo
la partita ma si sono accorti te faccio
sempre quelli indifferente fischietta
fischi come si fa a parlare per mib i
premi marco cosa sta che appena passa
questo passa se si chiamerà 6 si gira
saper cespuglio nel cespuglio al
creativo è mai divertente che la
classifiche come casette queste qua no
ma che in chiave
ciao amici per piacere conoscerlo
questi sono insieme no no no no no no no
no no no no alpino zitti zitti ma
qualità ma pecori presto corri corri
corri corri corri by ma dov'è il tipo
non so nel in acqua basta un po come ha
fatto per effettuare è la vita del
cespuglio al giorno d'oggi un casino
perché non inter non c'è semplice studi
mila volte si sono pc scopi girata poi
passare quale azione e non l'ascoli ciao
amici
non badate amen bugli l'acqua cespugli
in acqua è normalissimo hyatt no che vi
salta la copertura fatti i cazzi tuoi
no addio quello gesù corre sull'acqua
per che spara me spara lui sparagli
sbaragli la mia speranza era che l'altro
gli sparasse giovane top 5
ma sarai anche stupido nel cervello
della tua vita stupida parlo parlo tanto
poi la prima occasione mi in groppa
nonché un piacere però
e si vola si vola verso la top ten
stavo scherzando stavo scherzando perché
hanno interpellarmi anche da dal tibet
giorno io hyatt male ma da che parte non
capisco dove mi sparano non capisco non
capisco non voglio più giocare a questo
gioco
quindi ragazzi questi erano era questa
erano cose successe durante la settimana
mentre testavano webcam nuova spero che
video vi sia piaciuto spero che adesso
che sia migliorata webcam l'audio perché
ci stanno i pannelli dietro e adesso
devo tagliarmi i capelli però a parte
quello dovrebbe essere tutto a posto
perché video mi sia piaciuto ragazzi
consenso momento mi piace anche
maxischermo allestito presso il chieti e
non ci vediamo
e cambiato il colore del telecomando ma
dai è diventato rosa ma come va bene va
bene va bene facciamo le cose un po più
omosessuali
[Musica]